recycling isn't taking it but it steamed
to the Commonwealth Games but we will
have a huge number of our writer and
getting that opportunity to represent
their formations while representing
Great Britain's obviously a massive
honor it's quite cool to race for
England as well and you get to kind of
compete against people that are usually
training in so that's quite a nice
opportunity Great Britain is split into
all the different home nation this you
can all have three four nations instead
of having one British rider you've got
nine plus in every event which makes it
very tough to be honest every training
session towards a major chance you
become more aware of every kind of
possible game that can be hard than
nutrition's a massive what if you're
feeling right and you're definitely
making the most of every session one of
the real benefits we have with our
partnership with science and sport is
that they have a huge range of products
so our toy fleets might be needing a
real high protein supplement where
perhaps some of our more endurance
riders overawed riders might need some
things a little bit more carbohydrate
apiece I tend to have quite a planned
race day nutrition strategy so when and
where you have no gels haven't been you
have in making sure we get fluids
because you can't have anything in the
race my events are fairly short so it's
making sure you get to lie in the best
possible shape for me I like to use a
science in sport caffeine girls
he's quite a lot of them give you
carbohydrate uncomfy